al menos seis personas han muerto esta
noche en la ciudad de Antioquia la
provincia de hatay una de las más
afectadas del terremoto que sacudió el
sureste de Turquía y el noroeste de
Siria hace dos semanas lo han hecho han
muerto esta noche por otra réplica otro
terremoto que ha sacudido la misma
región ya ha afectado donde hay miles de
edificios completamente de ruidos y ese
nuevo terremoto de 6,4 en la escala de
richter ha causado la el fallecimiento
de seis personas más que quedaron
atrapadas de debajo de sus escombros en
las redes sociales turcos muchos de los
vecinos se quejan de que estas personas
han quedado atrapadas bajo lo que antes
eran sus casas porque no han recibido
durante estas dos semanas desde que
empezó el primer terremoto tiendas de
campaña ni contenedores en los que se
podrían quedar han llegado a la región
algunos sin embargo muchos de que se
quejan de que no han sido suficientes y
es una de las que de las necesidades más
amplias ahora mismo contenedores y
tiendas de campaña para esas personas
por lo tanto Según dicen sus vecinos
estas personas después de no recibir un
cobijo donde quedarse por las noches gé
en muchos casos volvieron a sus antiguos
edificios muchos de los cuales porque
las tareas de identificación Cuáles
edificios han sido dañados y cuáles No
aún no han terminado estas personas
después de volver a sus casas se habrían
quedado atrapadas debajo de los
escombros